[Music]
in drug dummy news submitted by Devin
I've got a strong immune system it works
okay
police warn of untrustworthy drug
dealers and offered away drugs to make
sure buyers receive the correct amount
so legit wait today that again
police warn of untrustworthy drug
dealers and they offer to weigh the
drugs to make sure buyers are receiving
the correct amount have to make sure
there's some cuz like I've seen that
couple police like a facebook pages and
stuff that are like kind of doing this
looks like a joke or whatever so then
they I've seen this I mean like Tim I
think oh my god they're offering to test
like
purity and stuff but I guess this one
they're making a joke about this is in
North Carolina by the way I mean Hill
Police Department so they're off they
took a picture of like what looks to be
weed or something like that on top of an
iPhone calculate just like this is how
much it actually you think if they're
dumb enough to follow this trap
they'll be captioned it with scam alert
the min Hill Police Department has been
made aware of a new scam that went
public to be aware of some untrustworthy
drug dealers are using their cell phone
instead of a certified scale to display
the weight of the merchandise that
they're selling by placing the drugs on
their cellphone they can type in
whatever weight they want
claiming it was the weight agreed upon
during a transaction please do not
become a victim of the scam contact us
here at the Minho Police Department and
schedule to meet with one of our
officers we can assist you by weighing
your purchase to ensure that you get
cheated out of what you paid for so
really if you fall for this shame on you
you probably on you we're thinking the
police department with live
yeah all right there to serve and
protect yeah or way your drugs they just
want to make sure some people make sure
that they can charge you with something
yeah every size we know any ones will
equip it's the police
so definitely yeah it's they don't make
sure you have the authentic stuff so
they're verifying clearly the check mark
please tell me someone fell for it I
don't think so oh I mean a lot of the
Danny no no there's always a case of
someone falling one of the comments are
just like okay I just laughed out loud
with this brilliant public service and
so then I mean a lot of we're just
joking because I mean they're feeling
like no one's falling for this but I
mean you know it's gonna be crazy hoping
then watch me like out there that police
force is legitimately the exactly like
on the outside
everyone's like okay that's that's a
funny joke or like that's dumb and
everyone misses it'd be like now that's
where you get the good stuff man she
bossy
he's got the hook up okay just draw hope
people but no one's coming in yeah yeah
or just yeah that's a super well
attention like sergeant's just sitting
there just like I just wanted to do a
really good thing for the community I
just want them to not be cheated yeah
he's like legitimate trying to stabilize
like the the the economic rates of the
drug he's like no no I don't people
getting ripped off for this anymore
let's let's start setting a standard for
this all right it's like yes or even
better he's like sitting outside the
police department with like one of those
like Charlie Brown wait your drugs here
whatever just say someone gets like
there's stuff waiting like the chief
just comes up he's like I'm sorry Jimmy
they ripped you off
imagine it crazy good [ __ ] to hear go
crazy alternate reality they're like wow
you got ripped off we're gonna go get oh
yeah go Jimmy where you go we had to go
pick up the FCC we're next Grimm come up
all right you Batman and Robin - you CC
f''fgf g5g down on mtv but you know it'd
be so empty without me so then finding
the source and the source damn go I saw
another post that was really funny of
another police department that was like
are you a drug dealer do you have
competition kind of works right it's
what it's funny because it's like who's
the first one look at six nines over
there just like a yuppie be like what
have you guys heard about yeah the gang
on the opposite side of the tracks yeah
what do you guys think about like that
program that like is a sweeter or like
one less place I had it we're there yeah
legal like there's here I think a lot of
that is really cool actually the the
legal injection sites just because like
I'm not I know that there's the argument
that this is like kind of normalizing
drug use and stuff but I think that from
like a public health standpoint making
sure that a lot of people have access to
like clean needles and stuff is like
weird and counterproductive that sounds
like I'm kind of mean like you look at
like cities that have needle exchange
firm exactly they already do do like so
much better
yeah you know what we're talking about
this is very common needle exchange
program so when you're done injecting
the marijuana you can
marriage you want it hey Juwanna I'm
heading out the door good weed that good
you mean yeah I like to snort mine
personally wait that's a thing no I look
at mines my ear and my butt I don't know
what's common how does it feel do you
make oh [ __ ] do I make us all the time
never uses they feel like can you
imagine like you some dudes like baby
from this bunny mouth it's like where's
that go baby now like you're gonna see
Devon Republic hey you want to hear this
pen no yeah bro what you doing don't
worry about it just stay in there 24/7
whatever you want to press the button
use some contraction do you know you're
like driving you actually whoa we have
some speed bumps like you know we always
found a lot of people's rectums never
expected me pin I bet there has been the
more you know have you seen the stories
of like people getting stuck being stuck
in their penis like we've done we've
done some Jay King these stories about
that it's yeah people like I remember
here like an Eminem or something stuck
in someone's before how do you fit that
some people are P Penn he says it's just
like a hose ow hey there are people that
try to regrow their foreskin alright
anyway no have you seen up the people
where they attach weights to the end of
their dig now just stretch their skin
and regrow their foreskin because why
would you just like why would you [ __ ]
with a piece at all is because they're
they're upset the way I didn't get a
choice in circumcision some people have
Charlie Brown's oh wait why are you
searching for this information how do
you know where to find this it's me what
sure it's a dumb question the good thing
is don't see really that makes I just
want to know the thought process behind
it I didn't question I was watching this
documentary was it that point
documentary actually I watched a few of
those yeah you know again
so back to things getting stuck in
penises yeah one guy put a screw into
his oh and then they got stuck oh whoa
go bigger something go screw himself
he's like well sure okay we did another
Jay King news episode where there is a
we do it as a Chinese kid who is trying
to and he allegedly was trying to stay
up to study for tests and stuff like
that oh that's a bunch of look but but
he said that caffeine wasn't working I
energy drinks and stuff wasn't working
so we took the next logical step and he
stuck a chopstick in his dick and he got
stuck in there and he he only went to
the hospital he went to the hospital
when his mom noticed that when they went
out for their morning jog he was running
weird there's a the family didn't want
to embarrass themselves or like okay you
have to sit down and think about it
that's me huh how are you gonna tell the
story where we don't embarrass ourselves
for the rest of there's no way to get
out of raise this question appropriately
almost like you're not surprised that
like the way it was found out was that
he was on his a morning job yeah right
yeah oh you're gonna say that she was
eating breakfast is she's missing her
favorite chopsticks I'm shits coming out
soon I swear favorite shop she has one
pair of favorite chunkiness
and that's the one that he was like
that'll do it yeah oh no oh god she's
like give it back his new superpower the
penis good
like a magazine with missiles like fall
into a hole he's like don't worry I got
this just keep shooting them into the
wall so we have something grabbed oh I
think he's just like what's it fall down
just like hey grab it looked like the
chopstick hanging and just like
translate yank it at the movie I didn't
do all this heroic stuff he's like babe
I got some before you takes out his
pants there's a rose in it and he shoots
it up to his hand he's like you you
created to make a skit about that every
rose has a piece obviously get thorns
and I was like your dick roses are red
violets are blue a chopstick a second to
my penis what should I do
[Laughter]
doesn't hit the market to the mark you
really add some heart I even know what
he said but I just instinctively went no
that's probably bad just replaying it
wasn't on the level of win cest but it's
pretty close wait so what was the story
it was this chopsticks story our story
we're talking the rest are talking about
weighing drugs oh wait you guys I think
we're getting better there's new things
we talked about putting vapes of Devon's
but yeah we're trying to save and then
blowing there you go he started with the
Suez talk so cars but yeah back to your
original question about saving Jackson's
sites I think it's I think it's kind of
a yeah
I think it's I think it's good we never
explained to Josh what that is oh yeah I
did a little exchanges like though you
turning your dirty manuals so they give
you fresh needles because yeah their
dirty needles it sounds bad yeah like
this it just sounds all bad
like I have done in like the data the
drug use hasn't really gone up but drug
deaths go down signature unless
communicable diseases from dirty needles
cuz that's mostly where it comes from so
if you're giving them clean needles are
gonna be the ideas they're gonna be
doing drugs anyway so you might as well
give them clean methods of doing it so
they don't transmit other diseases and
then it spreads it in the population
yeah they catch them all I mean I was
never drunk girl he's gone dude with
that you're like y'all can use
combination oh god I love this like
growing up I like I've never been afraid
of needles but just like the thought of
just sharing yeah it's gross right even
though you clean it it's okay no it's
eclectic clarify they're taking the old
needles of destroying em and sanitizing
the bottom later I don't think you have
to you clarify for everybody yeah again
nine times
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]